gentlemen know when sky has been out for
a little while now mmm we obviously last
week talked about in relation to the the
pre patch version the post patch version
initial sort of like feelings on the
game it was Tuesday you reviews since
got off seven out of 10 on gamespot and
the I feel like with a lot of
conversations in the office about this
and the reasons why you like out of the
same reasons I like or like the very
similar to while I guess I'm saying a
bunch of it using nice for I don't know
i could wring your review I couldn't
read and and then obviously there's a
lot of people who are super pissed about
the game for a number where my dinosaurs
Sean Murray I know right there's not
really funny Jurassic Park that show the
pre and post versions that's pretty good
and rocky were playing a bunch as well
yeah I'm playing a really good amount
unfortunately with throughout the three
live streams we've done I've had to
restart my save freely yeah so first one
we did because of bugs no just because
of like showing the game so IDC
obviously I gotta start over again under
from save so Ivan and then for the patch
had to restart to save whatever um have
not finished it whatever that ending is
yeah um but yeah I I've really liked it
and I I walked in from within the first
two hours like realizing that I would
like it and that also i let my hype
level before the game likes your like
expectations when ya so when I when I
got into I was like okay I can do this
this is what I imagined this game to be
and I mean I'm really into it okay so
let's talk a little bit a bit I guess
where we are with it cuz it's been I
mean it's a full-price game it you know
it includes quite a lot of repetition
and so I want to kind of like talk to
you guys about like how we feel about it
you know a week and we can some change
add I feel like I have like this
ridiculous like weird abusive
relationship with this game where I
really like us I really like being in it
I think it's incredibly simplistic but I
just I enjoy exploring in games already
like I'm I played World of Warcraft a
day for years and I like I hardly ever
partied up but i doing i just left
soloing i liked exploring Azeroth
Tara Plato's game say more fallout same
in Skyrim like these games take me
forever to complete because I just love
ambling around and this is basically a
game about happening around but his
[ __ ] crashes all the time for me like
I've had me outside of like having
problems where you know like just
structural problems where like you I
problems where I've like accidentally
done stuff for I didn't know what to do
for a while or I couldn't figure out how
to use this menu and one of the biggest
problems I had over the weekend was I
was trying to I'm following the Atlas
path and any time I tried to warp jump
into the system it would like crash like
I literally tried 15 times I had that
happen to me with one warp point and so
what I did to fix it which you shouldn't
have to do but what I did was is I did
something else first okay saved my game
and then tried it again I like went to
his space station literally got out of
my ship got back in yeah just to like
trigger something new and the chain of
events and that helped so yes the game
it does crash at times what I what I did
was go around that system it's like a
figure that's just wanted or something
you actually the very first time I went
into a black hole the game crash nose
like that is meta and intelligent as
hell I know you're a GI dearly gave the
game a 10 right there and that's funny
you mentioned to get in and out of the
cockpit thing because I use that like I
use f5 and is in a bethesda game where
I'm terrified of with Bethesda games
crash all you know relatively frequently
as well and I'm non-constant using that
Robbie using that as well like I feel
like I'm jumping in and out of my
spaceship because every time you exit
your spaceship it saves once i saw that
restore save i was like okay that's what
i'm spamming yeah um i actually haven't
had as many crashes with the game yeah
as as much as I've had in Game issues
yeah we'll have one where I guess I
happen to land near like a her idiom
pillar okay get on my ship get back my
ship and then like ship just is stuck
and Mary had this exact same problem
right ship gets stuck in the Iridium
pillar ship is cool xplode I respawn and
I rise over Hill and my ship is on top
of the Iridium pillar Oh
have to mind steps in order up to get to
it my ship's broken when I'm on top
which I took 10 minutes to get up there
I mean it was a nightmare but yeah like
those are real deal real deal breakers
and when I hear Mary have been having
the same problem like that seemed like a
very one-in-a-million thing yeah but it
wasn't like I just landed next to me was
it was fine I wasn't touching it like
and you know the game also lands for you
so you can't like necessarily prevent
these things when you'd like to yeah I
mean as far as crashes though I haven't
had that problem it's interesting the
child is like splitting up both ways
Ronan seven saying that's funny saw
streamer entering the black hole for the
first time let me also crashed somebody
else saying I watched a couple of
streams lucrative eight saying I lost
couple the street watch couple streams
in the game crash for almost everyone at
time machine saying never crash for me
you know you can yeah you can go either
way and in a weird way this feels like
again it feels like I'm playing I'm
exploring a universe which is like like
broken or something like it feels like
the crashes are they've cut they've
comes become so habitual that and with
the Atlas stuff like this this whole
like is the universe there hasn't been
designed for you or is it this other
thing you know like that malicious demon
theory kind of matrix e shit's going on
as well right so then when I see the
game oh it's just like part of the game
or like that's what my brain is done to
like accept that reality or something
and I'd almost expected on a pc game but
I'm playing on PlayStation 4 yes so
peculiar that it does it a lot is a bit
strange what do you think about I guess
the game outside of the technical issues
and you know are you still enjoying it I
used to playing it you know past the end
of you know the one of the missions as a
work and are you still finding joy
playing no man sky the latter question
is that was the correct one but yes i am
still playing it I can't help but turn
it on at my desk and it's preventing me
sometimes from getting work done because
I essentially i finished the alice path
and so now from where i am i'm trying to
get to the center of the galaxy just as
you would if you didn't follow that path
and what it's become is sort of a
repetitive cycle where I get enough
materials to make warp cells fuel my
hyperdrive you travel as far as I can
inevitably
my like the warp drive that makes your
hyperdrive better it breaks after a few
things right so you have to get more
mature and I found myself doing that and
I'm am I having fun anymore no fun is
the right word but I'm enjoying what I'm
doing like right because really I know I
know what's what the what you get at the
end of the game like I'm not trying to
figure that out right but i but i'm
still enjoying the challenge of
progressing and when I need to sort of
pick up the pieces and repair my stuff I
find myself back on a planet I still
feel happy when I find a cache of like
real resources I still feel tensed when
it's like actually I had an experience
really difficult survival until after
beating the Dallas path in the review
now I'm finding planted really kick on
my butt so that's been kind of nice but
the Atlas path for me was really the the
meat of the game the thing that I
latched onto you the most so without
that there is something kind of missing
but I still like it and it sounds like
they're adding so much i'm really
curious where it's gonna go and i and i
want to be at a good place you know with
my my ship my gun and stuff by the time
that all comes yeah it's it's an
interesting sort of experiment in
finding I don't know finding your own
fun or something like I I had this idea
that I wanted to get starbug from Red
Dwarf you know the British sort of all
my television show I wanted to get like
something that looked like Starbuck cuz
that's kind of what no one's guy feels
like to me and and I spent like three
hours just like going from like space
station to like you know on planet
little trading posts and going to a
different system to do and then
eventually I found this like relatively
round relatively green looking machine
and I got it and I'm like yeah I'm not
I'm not necessarily sure if it's fun but
it's like interesting it's interesting I
was actually really enough my wife was
watching me play and she was talking
about how it reminds her of the stuff
like the first two parts of spore like
remember spore was like it was four
different games right basically he just
kept going right the first part was like
really dinky 2d kind of thing and you'd
evolve and Walla and then the second
part wasn't he crept onto land and like
that was really fun and I never played
the foot like I didn't really enjoy the
city stuff i just hit reset and go do
the first two parts again so there was
no real challenge in it but it was just
like novel and interesting and that's
kind of what i feel like no man sky is
just without the reset button i keep
going
back just to go back yeah what about
what about your self robbery are you
playing it with the sort of like end
mission in mind are you just enjoying
the moment to moment I love the moment
moment I love turning off my brain uh I
mean usually you know we've talked about
it like you said it best like there is
something inherently like comfortable
that I get with with finding like right
now I found a plan system that loves
plutonium right and I'm actually still
here because I'm not like five million
dollars I was like five days ago I go
back and forth I'm loving up my plan is
now I'm decided is to just make a lot a
lot of money and then just go for it
just track you just like what you're
gonna like I swear I love it it'll be a
lawyer all your 20s and retire but you
like your 30th birthday come out but for
me it's getting to where I am now you
know I like hitting the market like the
trading in aspects prior to that it was
like I actually feel like the systems
prior were really crappy like but it's
what I wanted from this game which is
you know I'm I like to dwell in and
imagine what our universe actually is
like right like there are a lot of these
awful planets and it's so cool to have
that contrast to like what there was one
planet where it was this acid rain like
oh this play it's kind of cool acid rain
storm comes in I'm getting my ass kicked
I'm like 10 minutes away from my ship
I'm digging holes in the ground like
it's tearing me apart so when you find
that you know whatever your your
favorite system may be whether it's
filled of life or a rare resource that
you know is it plentiful on on planets
like a weird animals weird-ass animals
whatever it is I don't know it's like
getting to that you know that though the
odds the finding that like that favorite
like a in the hell yeah it's just that
is fun and so I'm content with where I
am right now um but you know in on the
flip side like I totally understand and
I like I knew from like that two hours
in like some people are not gonna like
this yeah it is not what the game played
the gate like you know you Ethan with
all the e3 gameplay clips that's like
the one out of a hundred planet right
like I feel like people forgot about
that
and so it becomes boring to certain
people when they land on that barren ask
moon or something like that and I think
that's kind of the problem because that
is boring and it's not fun when you're
looking around doing nothing the trick
is to get back in your ship and haul ass
into space and find a different planet
that's what I found whenever I found
myself bored dejected it was just like
wake up get out of Rights a lot of
places I go check out don't burn out on
that stuff yeah this isn't a game it's
like really trying it's weird like this
can go either way right this is either
like super apologist on my part or it's
it's just like a weird inside the
reality of modern games but like so many
years mollycoddle you and try and keep
you entertained on a moment-to-moment
basis this game is so [ __ ] a pathetic
yeah enjoyments just like this is the
way it is reger it out right and but
then here's the other side of it and
he'd gamer makes a really good point in
the twitch chat and if this game
launched for forty dollars then the
price would have been fair but the fact
is the price is sixty dollars which is
way too overpriced in my opinion I feel
bad for the developers hope they don't
get too much hate for such a small team
they did a great job obviously when
you're reviewing the game price is like
a difficult thing to like include
because it's such a weirdly subjective
thing it'll change things will go on
sale that's true in a review when a game
is 60 is different than when a game is
40 right or it shouldn't be but yeah
yeah but it's a different a price into
account oh and especially where they
have stated with patched practice coming
up with like you know uh space cruisers
in base building down the road yeah
maybe they promise yeah some extra stuff
but I guess you know in the review we
tend not to talk with the price but
let's kind of talk about here a little
bit and we're in the sort of privileged
position where if we know we don't we
don't get all our games for free be get
some games for free it allows us a
little bit more leeway in the games we
do spend money on and for you know a lot
of people do you think maybe a full
price for this is a little bit too much
it's hard to say I mean cuz I've played
the game right like we got a copy for
review I didn't pay for it but I am
every day flirting with the idea of
paying a hundred bucks on ebay for the
limited edition right yeah because I
really like this game and that's a
really beautiful package and I think
it's a beautiful way to contain this
thing that I that I respect I mean it's
hard for me to know like I am biased
because of our job but like I think that
there are a lot of games that command
value in different ways
I think that this game you could find an
argument very easily if just not the
amount of things to do and see right you
know so many people love to equate time
with value like when a game is 20 bucks
and it's only two hours what the hell
yeah well okay this one you can play
probably infinitely but like how long
have you played over at this point chief
of 50 so much okay so yeah that's not
about a return on investment yeah no I
you go to a movie nowadays it's 12 bucks
yeah Howard half out of it like I don't
know what what do you think yourself up
I'm Sabrina wait the value proposition I
mean just from you know I think the the
hook for me has always been like in real
time arriving in a space or I'm sorry at
a solar system and and going through
atmosphere and landing on the planet and
it does that for me and I've always
wanted that since the day i had a toy
spaceship Roy my hand and I was 10 years
old it's really cool experiences yeah
one of the most fulfilling things I've
everything i when i played elite
dangerous for the first time i tried to
do it it didn't do it i was like you
know what i mean and that's it's a
beautiful game but like you've that's
things is you feel so claustrophobic
when you arriving in these systems yeah
yeah I discovered it but oh I want to
get out of the spaceship you know and
this game is able to kind of meet both
worlds and it's legitimately like what I
wanted and I'm totally contend with it
see I think it's like definitely worth
sixty dollars and it's definitely worth
your time if you were the type of person
who enjoys that type of like it to me
it's such a one type of game it's so you
can enjoy games that are like that like
peak your fascination are about
expiration and about you know fee if
they're not shooters or like
narrative-driven experiences are very
linear focused games like you know call
of duty or you know any number of third
person action games if that's what
you're looking for at least and [ __ ]
go somewhere else but lowly to me it
feels like if you were into that type of
expiration what the hell is this thing
it's great right now mary-kate & Robin
put it together these videos of all this
weird nonsense I really hate these
animals I really hate them I don't know
you get some cool ones though I love the
roll the dice look at that
weirdo if you like [ __ ] like this by
this video game they're all weird though
and like someone and I was criticizing
that in my review that like you anything
me and Mike talked about it like after
the 20th weird animal like it starts to
you sort of stop being surprised and I
put something like that in my review and
someone was like well you know from
God's perspective like all these
creatures are special it's like okay no
sorry that's not he said that's already
said this already said misrepresent it's
a hard argument disagree with an alien
looking down on us would be very
confused by what we are and think that
we were just weird creations alright but
these are amalgamations of things that
we know to exist on planet earth for the
most part slaps together in a way we're
just laughed together I just that's the
only animal right here we're like Tiger
up that actually looks kind of normal
yeah like a plan sorry I let's move on
higuera Suzy animals in this game freak
the hell out of me no magic creepypastas
freak me out as much as these entities I
mean that's a good reason to play the
game with nothing else and I totally get
what people are down on it I I
definitely like we talked we talked two
thousand times about the expectations
that were leveled against this game I
feel like I talked a thousand times like
in like various different like Twitter's
and videos and everything about how they
were running a dangerous sort of you
know line with with the way the trailers
are coming out and with like I know Sean
and from when we talk to me did all
those projects about the game the one of
the things that they said like very
early on to me was that he wanted this
game to be like my craft not in terms of
how applies but in terms of how people
came to it that they didn't know the
recipes that they didn't know what I was
about it and know why it was four times
four and I think in being vague about
what this game was especially when I
feel like the multiplayer stuff that was
the thing I wish he'd like nailed an
early cuz I'm pretty sure there was no
much better like that game is a big deal
for a lot of people yes for sure I'm so
I think that like in trying to be vague
he was trying to be like to allow there
to be Wonder and I think there is a
certain backlash about that were people
who aren't like engaged in the minute to
minute of game reporting like we are
exactly thought that there was something
else and wasn't I kind of got that but
in terms of everything else like you
know technical stuff notwithstanding I
think it's a good game it's our great
game it's
wonderful game that there are parts of
it that are certainly great um but it's
pretty good gets me about the whole
conversation like you promised this and
that and it's not here is like this game
had to come out right it had been a long
time coming they sort of exhausted the
hype train fuel early on I'm gonna show
me breathing down their neck i imagine i
mean i don't know but yeah like I'm sure
Sean wanted to put everything in the
game that everyone right now is saying
is missing right but that's not always
possible games are really expensive and
they got to be finished long before
they're shipped it'll be interesting to
see what what the version of ms coexists
six months from now or a year from now
guess what let's wait and find out Peter
Brown thank you so much yes me and Rob
boundary thank you as ever thanks thanks
everyone is sending questions as well
much obliged for any thoughts on no one
sky please put them in the comments
below
you